I mean it's fantastic to see you here at
London Film and Comic Con winter I've
been enjoying it so far
it's been a huge huge event for me it's
mine I have done one before but not
since I've been doing Game of Thrones as
well and the whole thing has become it's
like you're taking a different viewpoint
on your whole of your life your career
and you keep thinking but it's okay
everybody
you're surrounded by people who care and
appreciate your work and that's as a
huge privilege it's it's a wonderful
experience good to hear I mean Gary's
very mention has been fantastic season
for you on the show
of course the Battle of Castle black
tell us a little bit about behind the
scenes of filming that battle and the
rousing speech you gave as well well the
speech you know I think for a lot of
people is a surprise because it could be
viewed as a rather negative character
was a bully I'm sure that for me because
I play the character he you sense that
it's that's the job and that's the best
way to do it yes he is very cynical
about human nature but with good reason
the teachers you know he's a product of
his own experiences we all and and then
to get this fantastic speech I've done a
lot of Shakespeare in my time and answer
suddenly said get it to Henry the fifth
moment you're going to get your once
more into the breach and to come you
know it's it's he is the hero of the
wall he's I think something online wrote
that it's it's the hero that the wall
deserves
not everybody's idea of heroism but he
does put himself on the line for the
shake of the castle for the sake of
others that was a huge gift filming it
we thumbed in the night and it was
torrential rain coming down and part of
the wall behind where the lift is in the
cause it's a huge quarry and the walls
of the quarry started to break with the
amount of water passing through it and
where they broke it became well as a
river there's literally River running
into the middle and we prepared to do
the speech and the water was just
falling on the sky like steroids and he
was filling up this very limited space
in the center of the castle and I got
down there I said what am I going to do
what am I going to do I can't do the
speech in the rain they said we we've
got to shoot it's too big everything is
fit to go except for the weather we've
got to go okay I said I'll go friend I
came down the stairs appealing to my
brothers that it's you know with me now
now with me we will if we fight if we
become one then Castle black will stand
in the morning even though they're
coming over the walls did the speech did
a blubber unlike always with film and
you go to do it again but the time I
came to do it again I said I'm losing my
footing because I'm standing in water so
they were boards down
they were planks so that out of out of
shot so that when I came down I'd be
able to have something solid to walk on
but of course they would
and it was filling up at such a rate
that by the time I walked back up to the
top and came down again it started to
float so they were literally floating
floating off when I was standing at sea
I was surfing across and I couldn't
believe it was waters is pouring off me
but it it kind of helped it was like my
god I'm in Blade Runner one of my
favorite fellows
so good of course you've got that
fantastic fight scene as well we tormund
Giantsbane having you tell me a little
bit back filming that yeah well we
rehearsed that for a long time a lot of
the moves a lot of the character and
Christopher plays Tommen is a very
inventive guy and he was always coming
up with new moves and I think I'll do a
forward roll here and I'll do something
and I was very sorry Alice Oh sort of
why why would you want it I'll just stab
you if you do but I think that the clash
of styles was very dramatic and it made
for great television Neil Marshall II
directed that has experience of action
the whole thing just you know the
ingredients just came together to make
something I'll certainly never forget
for the rest of my career my life and of
course at the end of the show the end of
the season we saw an Stannis and
Melisandre coming in what do you make
about that what do you think they're up
sue well I'm obviously allowed to say
very little about what I'm shooting at
the moment but the fact that I am
shooting I think you know people have
gathered you never saw sir al-assad I
injured yes dragged away so don't be
surprised if you see him again and don't
be surprised if he's still a lone wolf
he doesn't really fall in he's very
cynical about human nature even though
as you say the King Stannis means well
he's got his own agenda it's like it's
almost better for my cut for me playing
the character to not read about other
people's stories to not know it that's
what it's like to be at Castle black
it's a solitary existence
so as disproving or suspicious as I am I
would never show it to him it's very
difficult I can't say too much because
as I say well I'd be giving away what
we're filming at the moment you can't
talk about what you're actually doing
but has it compared going back shooting
this season to previous seasons for you
as an actor I think that the sees the
the big episode at the wall that was a
film in its own right
its standalone it changed everything for
me and it changed my position with
people who want to talk about it
wherever I go in the world that it's
it's it's now I feel very very much part
of it I feel and I hope to deal with
that responsibly that for people who
love it and for the writers I don't I no
longer feel like an actor was playing a
bit of a part in something I feel very
much part of the fabric of Game of
Thrones and that's privileged
you